it's International Women's Day and we're
here to celebrate the cultural economic
and social achievements of women around
the world I've got one amazing woman
here with me this is Patricia bright she
is the new cover girl for Glamour and
we're here to talk about all things
International Women's Day I'm really
excited as well I love the idea of just
empowering and supporting women even
just by telling my own story tell me has
anybody really helped you on the ladder
to success today is there one woman that
particularly stands out who wasn't a
member of your family I would say I've
got loads of inspirations in this space
of the internet in YouTube and there's a
lady called Marie Forleo who's kind of
like a motivational speaker she has this
amazing course and I remember her just
sharing her story and just being really
inspired by her in this digital space as
a young black woman growing up in the UK
today did you feel the opportunities
were open to you or did you feel you
often faced brick walls and closures I
felt like things would be maybe a touch
harder for me because one woman too
black that not necessarily everyone
would know where I came from or
necessarily relate to me but you know I
was lucky enough to be part of two
things right when I got my first job the
way I ended up getting that job was by
attending something could the Women in
Technology dinner and I was also part of
a community called
SEO which was to get black people into
all the top investment banks at the top
law firms and all the top kind of
financial institutions so I had the
backing to get myself into those circles
so that whatever limitations there were
that I could at least try and be part of
a community who would support me through
them but the fact that I needed to be
part of things like that to get the
roles obviously shows that there were
some barriers but I was happy that there
are opportunities like that for me who
told you about these opportunities very
hard to know because growing up I didn't
know so I first worked in investment
banking before I started becoming a
youtuber and I studied accounting and I
met a
guy who was on a finance course and he
got a job a banking is like there's
really good opportunities check out the
website for one of the first films that
I worked for and there was an
opportunity to come for this Women in
Technology dinner what do you think the
biggest barrier is for young women today
who are trying to succeed in the
workplace I think one of the barriers is
sometimes not believing that you can
necessarily do it I think it's really
important for girls to know that you can
break through it and you can bring your
feminine energy to a space and actually
make it better do you think that maybe
when you say bring your feminist energy
do you think that women feel they can't
be themselves do you think they feel
that they need to be maybe or reserved
or more masculine in some way I do feel
like people feel like they have to go
one way or the other so I'm quite
dominant woman sometimes I'm like oh
maybe I should be a bit more girly and
then there are some who are a bit more
maybe reserved and they think maybe they
need to change themselves but I think
not every individual the best way to be
successful is to be your best version of
yourself
there isn't an issue with it you just
have to kind of own that and share it
with the teams or the people that you
work with that this is the way you are
and they can adapt themselves to work
with you can you think of a time that
you've made a crack in your glass
ceiling that you feel particularly proud
of I feel like I'm doing that now with
my own youtube channel and just kind of
create in my own space and my own
businesses and I've worked with
different management companies and
agencies in the past which often were
run by men but you know I decided to
kind of bring a lot of stuff in-house
and partner and employ more women and
more girls not for positive
discrimination but just because I
connect with them as one I feel like the
fact that I'm able to do that and be in
that position is breaking a glass
ceiling have you ever had a time where
you faced discrimination at work and how
did you deal with it I'm not sure if it
was that I felt that it was specifically
discrimination maybe feeling a little
bit left out as I keep mentioning I was
really an amalgam
environment and it's like don't really
know how to get involved you know you're
talking about the football or your
favorite beers and that kind of stuff
and I'm just like I like lipstick but
I'm not gonna have that conversation for
me overcoming it was kind of having to
just get involved like when they went
down to the pub I would join them at the
pub and have a bit can you think over
time as a woman that you've triumph over
tragedy
I wouldn't say triumph over tragedy I
just say try out you know childbirth
being a mum I feel like that to me is a
triumph and you know being self-employed
as well under mum and having to combine
the two how do you juggle it all how do
you make it all work it's not easy it is
quite hard to make it work I think
routine order and just you know being
that multitasking woman is the way to
make it work what does feminism mean to
you today for me personally feminism
means appreciating the difference
between men and women
I feel fundamentally we're very
different and the values that women have
are extremely extraordinary in my
opinion and it should be on the same
level and we should be treated in the
same way that men are even though we are
different what I hopes and dreams do you
have for women for your daughter in the
future I hope that women will feel
confident to embody themselves as they
are and that they don't have to change
or adapt or be more one way or more
another way to fit in or to get what
they actually deserve as a human being
in life so for more videos like this and
if you want to see what happened behind
the scenes of my color shoot make sure
you subscribe to the glamour UK YouTube
channel